look at that it's the missing panel
about here
odin must have stolen it
but why
so one of the north squads that is
mentioned throughout god of war that we
only really see through paintings and
murals on a wall is tyr
in today's video we'll be discussing how
tears depictions in god of war compare
and contrast to those of actual norse
mythology as always with these videos
there will most likely be spoilers so if
you haven't played the game yet or you
just don't want the story spoiled please
click away now
in the game tier is seen as perhaps the
most loved and respected deity of all of
the norse pantheon
despite being a god of war tyr was still
seen as being fair and just and it
seemed as if he spent most of his time
travelling to different realms making
peace and learning of different cultures
the vast knowledge that tier was able to
obtain and share from his travels meant
that he was seen as a natural-born
leader being trusted by all of the races
of the nine realms even including the
oyotna who despite being fierce enemies
of the isaiah still saw tear as an ally
the contrast between tyr and his father
odin is very clear for all to see
where odin became obsessed with the
giants attempting to almost erase them
from existence tyr took it upon himself
to stop his father and his brothers from
entering jotunheim it was this final act
of betrayal that led odin to eventually
kill his son but there are still many
remnants and temples scattered
throughout the game devoted to tyr most
of what we see in god of all regarding
tyr in terms of the role he played and
his actions have been slightly changed
and embellished to suit the storyline
but tyr being a fair just and respected
deity is definitely something that was
taken directly from norse mythology
in norse mythology tier was seen as one
of several deities associated with war
but he was also responsible for
maintaining law and justice
although tyr does feature in norse
mythology many believe that he may have
originated from a much older germanic
god named tivas who assumed the role of
chief deity that is until he was
replaced in terms of popularity and
authority by odin and thor who would
both share his role as gods of war
the identity of tyr's father is
something that has been questioned over
the years and god of war quite commonly
in norse mythology tyr is one of the
many sons of odin but there are some
sources that claim his father was
instead himir the giant best known for
accompanying thor when they were able to
fish the wild serpent from the bottom of
the ocean
the identity of tyr's mother is
generally unknown as she's never
referred to by name so even though he's
regarded as quite a popular deity there
is still much about tyr that is shrouded
in mystery
despite having quite a large role in
norse mythology tear really features in
any stories the most well known tale
that tyr appears in is the binding of
fenrir
when the wolf fenrir was born the gods
feared that because of how quickly he
grew he would pose a threat to them all
in order for odin and the rest of god to
control fenrir he was raised amongst the
isaiah in asgard but even as a young pup
the early god who dared to approach and
feed him was tyr
eventually it was decided that fenrir
would have to be bound to contain him
and the gods had a variety of chains and
ropes crafted to hold fenrir when fenrir
became suspicious the gods told him that
they were merely testing his strength
applauding him every time he was able to
break free from his bindings
sending word to the dwarven realms they
were able to craft a magical ribbon that
was extremely flexible but could never
be broken regardless of how hard one
struggled
when the gods presented fenrir with this
ribbon the wolf began to suspect
trickery and refused to be bound unless
one of the gods placed their hand in his
jaw as a pledge of good faith
none of the gods were willing to step
forward and volunteer as it would mean
certainly losing her hand
the only one brave enough to step
forward was indeed the just and fearless
tear who without hesitation placed his
hand in fenrir's jaws and as he expected
when fenrir was unable to break free of
the ribbon he chomped down and swallowed
tyr's hand
this story does a fairly good job in
highlighting the selflessness and
bravery of tyr were all of the other
gods were unwilling to lose a hand tier
knowing that binding fenrir would
guarantee the safety of his people was
willing to sacrifice his hand for the
greater good
for the most part tears depiction in god
of all remains fairly true to that of
norse and germanic folklore and tear is
definitely a god that i would have loved
to have seen appearing just more than
paintings but let me know what you guys
think
is tear a god that you had previously
heard of do you think tier may not be
dead at all and we may see him in a
future game
let me know in the comments below
you